hello boys and girls we're gonna watch
gravity falls what by 17 or 18
18 18.
we are the adults educating children on
fleek
right guys hey
john they should go to patreon
absolutely where you can check out the
full-length watch along version where
you sync up with the time code plus a
bunch of other shows thank you to all of
become superjects and leave a like too
right john leave a like that helps the
channel out also comment leave your
thoughts we want to hear from you about
this show that's current slap your lap
john style yeah and talking
that's right man it's good cut points
anyway the boy is a prepper i don't
think it is help me
boys and forever
for editing down these highlights we
love you you're the best yeah
cut
[Music]
focus deputy remember your training easy
easy you're almost there
oh dang it i almost got the treasure
the time we spend together is treasure
enough
these cops do not ever do their job
reckon we should report that or go for a
ride in our new convertible
why not do both gents
[Music]
tyrannosaurus rex definitely a dia
dialophasar you
know there's got to be another word for
like a flying flying like absolutely
like
yeah or uh
that or uh
tears through the sky in an arid
dynamic sort of way a wingasaur
and maybe start with a p yeah
and they have like tactile you know like
features so you could you could suggest
their form that way
like a terrible
tactile could i go to the bathroom save
all questions until after the tour
[Music]
oh
gross sorry kid finally waddles we have
the whole house to ourselves what do you
think dance party
[Music]
just like that john hughes movie can i
tell you a secret you're my favorite pig
in the whole world a pterodactyl is
gonna eat you man
that's what they should call
all right outside now it's not safe for
waddles outside there's predators and
barbecuers he should be inside like a
person people don't roll around in their
own filth
except for seuss
maybe we're the ones who should be put
outside huh huh
oh do a wattles home alone riff i don't
like where this is going something big
enough to rip the roof off a car if we
get a photo of this thing we'll be
heroes yeah i won't get all the babes
you'll be fending off smooches with a
stick
shut up man or the stick dude i hear
what movement sticks too sometimes tap
supposed to be this sticky
jurassic park preacher will grab that
stake cross through the string and set
off cameras a b and c and nothing can go
wrong high five
i like this plan
oh
hi i'm bobby renzobbi and what you need
is the huggy wuffy tummy bundle i could
hold ten babies at one you know what
you're thinking doesn't work for pigs
[Laughter]
[Applause]
thank you justin roiland
to get a huggy wuffy tummy bundle yeesh
isn't knitting matching sweaters for
that pig enough
nope
those are on etsy somewhere not now kid
i got some tourists coming through
grunkle stan i know you're not crazy
about waddles he's a fat naked jerk
fine yeah yeah i promise thanks dad
don't be weak grunkleson i present to
you a unicorn made out of corn the
cornicorn
i i don't know i'm tired
[Laughter]
what a rip-off kids we're leaving
no no
don't you hurt that pig grunkle stan
that's a wing if camera b got the wing
then the one that should have got the
rest is camera c what happened to video
recorders in your phone the creature
don't spill it man no
but wait if you have the negative you
can start over just 10 minutes without
this pig in the house is that so much to
ask
dad pterodactyl's gonna kill that pick i
know
it's the only possible outcome but
grunkle's dad it's not safe out there
there's predators oh brother
oh
no no
[Music]
i can't believe you man yeah he saw the
creature yeah
with his own two eyes
it took him took what the pig
it took waddle what to say about waddles
oh
no
wow
eaten by a pterodactyl bro what
what else grunkle stan you didn't put
him outside
what
no uh look it went down like this see so
there i was in the living room
golly when all of a sudden
oh [ __ ]
so i
i started said him right in the face
but he played dirty
huh
oh
that really happened
why why could you have taken me
uncle stan you tried to save them
oh
no
[Music]
that's it no pterodactyl messes with my
sister we're gonna go out there catch
him and save your pig oh christ
how would we even find the little guy
huh we follow that yes
or you know we could just call it a day
maybe hit the pool hall or uh
yeah let's go
save woggles waddles
him too that pig is being digested right
now it's pterodactyl man actually nobody
knows how to pronounce this because no
one was alive back in dinosaur days so
uh oh jeez almost ran over my own head
there
wow
[Music]
oh no i love the guy but sometimes he
messes stuff up since when
sorry dude sorry dude look a fairy
oh sorry dude i killed that fairy
not cool man not cool i got to tell you
something okay but before you do check
out these matching shirts i made for us
who's this guy right here you totally
you dude and these rays indicate
friendship oh
oh
sorry john you can't come on the trip
but the drawing is so beautiful oh
looks kind of hairy down there come on
grunkle stan you can handle it you
punched a pterodactyl in the face
remember oh yeah
i did do that didn't i
my what suspicious laughter
need someone to tag along and tell weird
personal stories no thanks nah come on
so there i am finding a raccoon for the
same piece of meat when our mouths get
closed and we kiss accidentally
you can't take a hint can you nope
no oh [ __ ]
[Applause]
whoa
[Music]
[Laughter]
ah
looks like i lost my sense of smell
i'll smell you twig what if he's being
worshipped oh that could be just like in
pirates of the caribbean too
wow that's kind of creepy that's super
whoa inside tree sap that's how they
survived for 65 million years cool is
that possible
this
life uh finds a way i genuinely
questioned him
[Laughter]
i could bring people down here and turn
this into some sort of theme park
jurassic sap hole
[Laughter]
i want to go to jurassic sap home
this could be a gold mine velvety rope
type deal there ticket booth here
i should have put that pig outside ages
ago
you said the dinosaur flew into the
house huh no wait uh
if you think about it
outside then you lied to me about it no
one's talking to me guys guys don't
fight why can't you be more like me and
dipper oh no all we got to do to find a
pig is follow this year yarn we just
keep following and following and when we
reach the end
oh oh
what which cave was it again
oh seuss you lost the trail come on damn
it
oh no john
[Laughter]
did my best
you ruined our photograph and now you've
got us hopelessly lost i made two shirts
and these shirts are useless they're
gigantic i have a different body type
dude oh so it's my fault i just thought
you know
unleash the dinosaurs
i fixed your lantern
[Music]
what are we doing
[Laughter]
[Music]
guys we need a plan to get out of here
zeus a pig costume i like it and we use
zeus as a human sacrifice i like it
wait did you hear that
[Music]
no he's going to die of violent death
right now
terrence is gonna crush him a second you
get there oh no she's gone deaf with
freer mabel come back here
guys
oh my waddles
i'll never lose you again
uh
oh yeah
yeah you would enjoy this
well welcome to the world little fella
[Laughter]
i wonder if he'll actually stay dead i
can live without the kid talking to me
all the time
telling me your jokes
making me laugh
god dang it
well this is just about the dumbest
thing i've ever done
[Music]
then you're gonna have to get through me
you flying devil come and get me
oh
god yeah
we have to get in a straight line what a
pterodactyl's eyes are so far apart that
if you stand right in front of it i
can't see you zeus you've been wrong
about stuff all day how can we dude look
i know i've messed up a lot i can be
sort of clumsy and it's not always as
lovable as i think yeah john
i'm learning a lot today
[Music]
oh
zeus you did it
[Music]
what's that
[Music]
[Laughter]
stab at thee
oh
[Music]
you saved him for me
yeah well sometimes you just gotta look
out
that scary-ass dinosaur yeah
[Music]
we're trapped
oh yeah
the geyser can shoot us back up
come on go go
froze before dinos
that church yeah it looks like the
church from the walking dead
season whatever that was are they trying
to say something
yeah this is a direct rejection of
creationism
i think we need to worry about the rest
of those dinosaurs i doubt it
[Music]
gravity falls dominion
[Music]
i ate my way through a dinosaur
[Laughter]
you go mcgucket
snorting that just tell i fold tough
luck sucker waddles was bluffing what i
had four aces that pig is a wizard
look at him he's taunting me
well done tv well done show
killing the game that was
perhaps the best one yet
it's an all-timer
and know what
word
word to your grandma
john your hair be looking crazy right
now snap does it is it stupid should i
yeah i just heard it like weird looking
right now okay
so weird i guess
anyway
john what's up what do you want to talk
about don't be self-conscious i'm never
self-conscious that's my secret cap now
you made it look good oh [ __ ]
i mean i'm just i'm just going off
inspiration from you i mean i watched
you just before we shot this you know he
did this like flip back and i watched
the curls bounce and that's like a
majestic thing to
do just like that too it's just like
that if you could scoot a few inches
forward and do that again
i think you'll find the results quite
illuminating uh yeah so you know just
game recognized game
game recognized game pterodactyl bro
tell them about the show the show was
great this week you guys i love the show
this week they did a lot of stuff in the
show that i
was dazzled by as both a fan of just you
know
uh
serial pulp
parisians say prehistoric prehistoric
yeah it came out that way yeah
prehistoric stories and things that like
you know this is a drawn cartoon but it
gave me some of those as opposed to
those live action cartoons but but no
but like a ray harryhausen like a clay
like a stop-motion you know uh uh
the names of of the correct references
are now eluding me but you know those
old movies where you would see them you
know make dinosaurs and and you know
it's like you know this lost island of
prehistoric creatures and so like it had
the ray charles animation style the ray
charles animation style absolutely yeah
and uh i loved how they jason and the
aragonauts yeah it's a good call yeah
definitely definitely good one sid did
he do sinbad too
in the voyage of the seven seas or
whatever
no
[Music]
that was which should kill that's
because kazam okay absolutely i'm the
only person on this timeline who doesn't
remember that movie being called shazam
it was always kazam to me so i would
like to just you know
uh
why are you getting distracted i'm sorry
i loved the themes that it i i loved the
flavors of that that it was and uh
baskin-robbins of cartoons right here
and uh the way that they can buy that
was stuff where it was more like
jurassic park where it's like it's both
eerie like i you you reacted strongly to
that initial image of the t-rex in the
amber and i was like yeah it has that
sort of like adventure kind of spirit of
those old uh ray charles animations but
also some of that like
spooky menace and eeriness of a jurassic
park type of monster movie and this was
a group a great example of the g falls
taken you know a premise that starts out
simple enough and then gets you know
big and heightened both in terms of its
uh aesthetics as well as the themes on
display what did you
think of the sode
i
have thoughts oh good
entering my brain
at a mile a minute right now
this is my
gathering thoughts face
it's good you have a good pensive uh
thousand mile stare
yeah you're the next ryan gosling
interesting
capital
[Laughter]
anyway
yeah
i think this was the first episode
this might sound like i'm insulting all
prior episodes and that's why i was
trying to think of a different way to
say this
but maybe you'll come to me sharper as i
speak
sorry spock
is that
this felt like the first time it was a
real
family ensemble show
i don't know why that's the phrase that
comes to mind they normally feel like
adventure of the week
with some
like the the serial tie-in character
stuff is important but that's kind of
secondary
and here's a reward for paying attention
yeah it just seemed primary for like you
got everything i think that's probably
the biggest difference is you had
everyone really involved this time like
they were all
important
players for this adventure they were
going on and then you watch as those
dynamics and everything we've seen over
the course of these 18 episodes have
been affected and how they've grown more
fond of each other and some resentments
that have also built up and what they've
learned so like everything they did with
like grunkle stan and mabel having that
fallout and him learning and he really
grew in this episode and did something
that was much more against his character
than he normally does like it normally
feels like
a hybrid between like a sketch animated
series in a show yeah like somewhere
between
there's some kind of weird line i could
draw it's like it's somewhere between
family guy and american dad on a kid's
version and this felt more simpsons
where it doesn't like reset every time
or earlier earlier where it's like the
reality doesn't reset completely each
time but it's only so related from
episode to episode yeah and i know i've
had my qualms about um
john seuss seuss
i've had my qualms about zeus before not
being funny but this is the first time i
felt like it was a real character
absolutely he's he's normally like ah
it's funny because he's he's dumb and
this is now the first time like oh he's
like a real person yeah and i really
really liked that i enjoyed that and i
feel like they did with everyone they
even made the prospector character fun
like i normally am like this is kind of
weird and creepy but he was he was
genuinely funny absolutely yeah so and
they and they played off what they've
built on him in the past yeah and like
to end your credit scene in the way they
do now as opposed to just uh like with
this episode i don't know what it's
gonna be like moving forward but the way
how
the episodes are usually the end credits
scenes are like a bit and i'm sure
they'll still have those i thought it
was nice to like i was like a sitcom
ending more so yeah we're just like
family these characters hanging out with
each other and you know it's more about
the back and forth and stuff yeah cancel
that order it's very sick joke very
psychological yeah yeah absolutely so i
i think that's why i found this one the
most endearing of them all
where it's like the the heart was always
kind of on display and you really felt
that earlier on that this was going to
be different you could see something
especially when it was like you watched
the pig then the pig gets taken and it
was that scene when everything just
started clicking for me like oh this is
going to be a different kind of episode
yeah absolutely 100 and it's it's cool
because they managed to do what a normal
episode does in that they do have
the high jinks and the wackiness the
high jinks the wagon is and and i think
what kind of separation charles this the
ray charles definitely all that other
jurassic charles vibes but uh the fact
that most episodes kind of take here's
one plot line about a couple characters
and here's a different plot line about a
couple characters and they'll stay
separate whereas here they very
gracefully
dovetailed into one
one overall story that still encompassed
the individual duel you know seuss and
dipper and grunkle stan and mabel
stories that were happening and gets you
to care more about wobbles
wiggles waddles
waffles walton goggles alton coggins
that's it from now on all you kids out
there know what hey kids
we have walton goggins
cult films walton goggins
or uh kids you might have seen him in
the hateful lake
four houses of a thousand corpses walt
didn't god
remember shanghai noon remember
justified children this is walton
what was that show where he played the
third wheel in a polyamorous
relationship kids love that sitcom with
walton goggins on network television two
and a half men definitely and they were
both walter he was the half man
he was the pig yeah yeah if i ever get a
teacup uh pig i'm gonna name it walton
goggins from now walton what i'm not
going to do yeah no if i'm upset it's
going to be full name well because then
if anybody overhears it they're going to
be like what is happening why poor
walton goggins that tomb raider's very
own walton goggins over there
righteous gemstone walton goggins i love
a world where everyone knows who walton
goggins is he's gonna become the
character actress
he's gonna become the character actress
margot martindale of like western e
character actor guys yeah you know with
the distinct look that man in the wasp
walter yoga
oh no we got to keep we now now it's a
challenge i'm officially yeah we're just
going to stay in the official movies are
there any more i can think of there's
got to be one
yeah
we already we got django i know you said
hate filets so yeah django i know one
more i'm reserving and in case we get a
call back okay yeah we'll move on from
here maybe we'll each get one
but for the callback yeah yeah uh but
yeah i thought this was the um i thought
this was probably their best it's like
is it the scariest no it's kind of
perilous yeah and uh yeah you guys are
actually kind of scary at times yeah for
sure they they actually manage even
though you know waddles isn't gonna die
i think it's just the fact that you
treat it as thoughts
walton goggins is not going to die and
never will die batman's furious
he's in fat man oh that's right he's the
name like the assassin guy good yeah
good good fat man's wanting guys see it
came around look at that the universe
smiled upon us but yeah the fact that
they at least just acknowledged the
possibility at least for mabel like i
feel like that's kind of a barrier on a
family kids oriented show it's like if
you acknowledge the possibility of death
and mortality you can't call it
i'm sorry i didn't i would like to
apologize for being cancelled
i can't say the old work
that's right i uh oh they're not even
asian why would you say they're an asian
family you know
i just didn't i'm overcompensating right
now because i don't know what they're
supposed to be so i'm just gonna assume
that there's something like you know
that i should
respect as a
white person that's why disney plus has
officially changed kenneth branagh's
movie title to murder on the asian train
because they knew that was racist
yeah he said calling him murder on the
asian train
fixes that problem by acknowledging the
monolithic culture that asian people
have become in the eyes of white folks
in the west
anyway we should wrap this video up no
this is where the kids are really
starting to tune in you know
let's get one more walton goggins
reference in there if i were man i would
take him a bread this whole time yeah i
know i could see the posters that i
could think of
uh
walton goggins was on a poster
he's had at least one or two like little
indie movies that he's been the lead of
right
now unless you're thinking of it's not
just the pony bill paxton from back in
the day
maybe maybe i'm just looking at the
wrong posters
he said oh hey
enemy of the state walton goggins [ __ ]
there we go i don't even remember him
he's he's but he's definitely on the
poster with will smith
he's the third guy on the poster
yeah he's in the bullpen with jack black
and i think owen what like a bunch of
people who were uh going destined to
become much larger stars or in that
bullpen i don't think ellen wilson's in
there
it's somebody though south green
maybe i'm not sure i feel like it's it
might it's it's somebody in that
category we'll find a shepherd comment
below
i feel like that shepherd would have
been like 60s
guys thank you so much for being here
uh this was
easily one of the best episodes for sure
comment below what's your favorite
walton goggins
yes kids go watch molten cocktail today
it's gotta have been at least one of the
movies you've seen
um subscribe click that bell
man we'll
catch you soon
goggins